what's up everybody I am Walter burn a Z
i'm heather ruth and i'm anna Wayne and
this is top five last week we took a
look at the best of one of the most
requested actors we've ever covered on
the show and as tradition goes this week
we take a deep dive into his worst
Michael Keaton is absolutely an icon an
American treasure he's played Batman
Beetlejuice the vulture that guy from
mr. mop the list goes on
but as with any actor who's been around
for as long as Keaton some films and
performances just missed the mark but
which of these performances are the
worst well in Keaton's case least best
let's find out these are the top five
worst Michael Keaton performances number
five Jack Frost in Jack Frost hey wait a
minute I didn't have this on a list I
love this movie Jack Frost is on the
list Walter it's terrible you only like
it because you're too sentimental that's
not true
oh yeah hey Walter remember awesome
comics yeah those are great times up
remember orbit report you guys were so
great on that show remember the
beginning of this episode Jack Frost is
the leader of his own upcoming band has
a beautiful wife a loving son and good
friends achieving his lifelong dream of
landing a record deal finally seems and
reach but it comes at the cost of
spending time with his family before
Jack can return home for Christmas he
dies in a tragic car accident a year
later his son Charlie builds a snowman
out of his father's old clothes and
please the harmonica he gave him before
he died through Christmas magic Jack's
soul is brought back in the form of the
Snowman Charlie just built Jack and
Charlie now have a second chance to
finally spend much-needed time together
where do I start with this movie it's
creepy and this is Keaton during that
point in the 90s when he was almost a
parody of himself
everyone knew his dick by 1998 and
nothing was unique about most of the
characters he was playing around this
time he's still charming and mostly
likeable as always but he needed a fresh
challenge Jack Frost wasn't it did you
just call me what bitch
well he does have a few decent scenes
with his son and the music is betta Blee
tolerable the concept of Jack Frost is
what portrays Keaton the snowman stuff
is too ridiculous and poorly done to be
effective in the way the filmmakers
wanted it to be even at the end when his
body manifests himself again and we see
Keaton in the flesh it's just weird
[Music]
King Robert from Game of Thrones plays
his best friend - man that guy's friends
die a lot in any case Jack Frost is too
schmaltzy for its own good with an
inconsistent tone that fails to utilize
its immensely talented lead the correct
way well I still like it go for you
Walter good for you number four Raymond
Sellars in Robocop I'm sure we'd all
just rather forget this movie ever
existed but it existed and Michael
Keaton was in it in the near future
robotics technology has advanced to the
point of military use overseas
however the creators of this technology
Omnicorp and their leader Raymond
Sellars are trying to bring the robots
home as in use them for law enforcement
in the United States this is heavily
fought by Congress until a police
officer named Alex Murphy is critically
injured in an attempt on his life with
the permission of his wife
Omnicorp makes him a cyborg with the
intent of using him in the field the
results don't go as planned when Alec
shows that his human side is still
intact and his emotions continue to play
a big role in his job as the first human
flash robot cop Keaton is largely wasted
as the film's villain we've seen him
play some really complex bad guys in the
past but Sellars doesn't have much to
him his motivations aren't anything we
haven't seen a million times before in
these types of characters he's a greedy
businessman who wants to make more money
by selling his robots to police
departments all over the country nothing
and no one will get in his way blah blah
blah blah blah he's mostly reserved in
this role with only a few Keaton isms to
brighten up a dreary boring remake that
seemed to miss the point of the original
make a more tactical
let's go with black there are some big
names in this cast in addition to keaton
samuel l.jackson and gary oldman have
sizable roles also Chucky Errol Haley
and Jay Baruchel make appearances Joel
Kinnaman playing the titular character
didn't have much to work with looked
like he could have used some backup
this is katana she's got my back I would
advise not getting killed by her her
sword traps the souls of its victims
number three
Doug Kinney and his clones in
multiplicity now we have our own
experiences with duplicates on this show
but for Michael Keaton's sounds great
right a Los Angeles construction worker
named Doug Kinney has a tough time
juggling his demanding job with family
life while on the job site a scientist
offers to clone Doug to make his life
easier
Doug goes through with the procedure and
a clone is created the clone handles
work while Doug spends more time with
his family a little too much time Doug
quickly feels overwhelmed by his new
house husband responsibilities and
creates another clone this clone takes
care of the household duties while Doug
looks to try and relax but the original
clone eventually clones himself and a
third damaged clone is made with for
Doug Kenny's out in the world
the original must balance them and his
family while keeping the secret from his
wife maybe that sounds a little
confusing but as a comedy the movie
definitely embraces the absurdity of its
premise Harold Ramis directed this and
there's actually a lot I like about the
film and Keaton's performances it's not
easy to create four distinct characters
all bouncing off each other in different
ways as the film goes on each clone
develops his own persona separative Doug
too becomes the macho one three becomes
the effeminate one and for well for like
people like it
I started out kind of hating this movie
and Keaton seemed to be on autopilot but
as we progress through the story there
are some legitimately funny bits look at
me okay
look ah that's a lot of ribs was that
like a slab or something brushing that
general read you but I did my mom bowed
out of there unfortunately it's not
quite enough to keep these performances
off the list a lot of the interactions
are clunky and the effects stick out as
very dated while his clones are humorous
they only rely on one personality trait
toward the beginning of the movie the
first clone thinks he is Doug when he
first wakes up this still could have
been a comedy if we explore that angle a
little more that would have been more
interesting and less reliant on gags
while these performances are definitely
on the worst list I would recommend
checking out the movie it's a funny
comedy with more Keaton's than you can
hit Ted we're in destroy Ted let's bring
Ted down yes number two
Johnny dangerously in Johnny dangerously
did you guys know 30s gangsters wear
eyeliner Johnny Kelly is a good
upstanding kid but when his mother gets
sick and needs money for an operation
Johnny decides to help out a local crime
boss to come up with the cash he takes
on the name Johnny dangerously and it
sticks with him into adulthood
now Johnny lives two lives one looking
after his mother and brother and the
other as an infamous criminal when
Johnny's brother Tommy becomes DEA he
starts cracking down on crime which
means the mysterious Johnny dangerously
is on the top of his list to take down
Johnny has to find a way to protect his
brother from other criminals while not
letting Tommy know that his big brother
is more than just a nice guy this is one
of those parody movies from the 80s that
was hit or miss the director of giant
dangerously Amy Heckerling was also at
the helm for hits like Fast Times at
Ridgemont High and clueless keith was a
younger man when this came out in 1984
and I just don't think he had his
trademark persona 100% down yet see you
breaking your mother's hot Tom white I
mean why my name is dangerously Johnny
dangerously the movie is weird and the
jokes don't work well nowadays in my
opinion but for all the wacky stuff
happening throughout this film I thought
Keaton would have been more off-the-wall
nuts his delivery is flat compared to
what would come later
and
we as a whole was a bit of a slug to get
through definitely one of Keaton's
subpar performances and the number one
worst Michael Keaton performance is
monarch in need for speed have you guys
ever played the need for speed kicks
well the movie is pretty bad after
street racer Tobey Marshall is framed by
another driver for unintentionally
killing his friend he spends two years
in jail when he's released the only way
to prove his innocence and get back at
the other driver is to beat him in a
high-stakes underground race called the
de Leon to get to the de Leon Toby has
to make it through bounty hunters and
cops looking to stop or kill him
Keaton's character monarch is some sort
of mysterious underground radio
personality who runs the de Leon and
announces it to people streaming it live
I'm not sure what he was going for with
this but it's not good Daryl no it's my
show I get shut up listen to me Michael
Keaton is an inherently cool guy he just
is he's one of those actors that people
like the personality of no matter what
role he's in in Need for Speed I don't
know if he was just trying too hard or
the direction was to blame but the
monarch character gets worse the more
times he shows up the thing you can
understand is great things in art dude
that's high art I have no idea where
this is going I just know what I like
y'all can walk home we all know most of
these are nitpicks Michael Keaton is one
of the most iconic Hollywood actors who
was still going strong to this day I
think we can all appreciate the talent
he's brought to any film he's been in
good or bad if you missed it last week
over on my personal channel I have a
discussion about something I've been
thinking about for years we all know
Keaton was a great Batman but what his
natural personality have been a better
fit for the joke join me over at
youtube.com slash awesome Walter and
let's get this conversation started we
want to hear what you guys think what's
your least favorite Michael Keaton
performance what do you want to see us
cover next on the show leave a comment
and let us know to keep in touch you
could like my Facebook page or follow
along on Twitter and you can find me on
Facebook Twitter Instagram or subscribe
to my animated movie reviews
right here on YouTube and you can find
me on Twitter Instagram or Twitter where
I stream on Wednesday nights we'll catch
up back here next week with a brand new
adventure here on top five
you
[Music]
[Applause]
you